you need to stop thinking like this if
you ever want to get ahead financially
your environment is a huge factor right
it plays a huge factor when it comes to
success and fulfillment in life once you
know how to multiply money you don't
have to chase money money chases you
need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation hates Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to
change your belief system change your
environment and get more productive with
Dan Locke and my take on his top ten
rules of success volume 16 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
1 change your belief system have you
ever wonder why you worked very hard yet
you don't get ahead financially I
remember when I was 18 19 years old that
I was hustling and trying to do side
jobs and try to turn to make a living
try to support my mom but I could never
get ahead financially I was desperate
for money I wanted to make more money to
be able to provide for my family but I
could never get ahead and I realized
that there is something in my belief
system back then there was holding me
back so you need to stop thinking like
this if you ever want to get ahead
financially if you ever want to be
successful if you want to be rich you
see money it's a very interesting thing
money doesn't go to the people who are
desperate for it that it's not it's not
enough to say I want to make more money
that all I want to increase my income
that I want to pay off that debt that's
not enough right if you want to make
more money money earn is a byproduct of
value creation so at the time I wanted
to make more money but I couldn't make
more money because I wasn't upgrading my
excuses if you want to make a million
dollars soft a million dollar problem
right if you want to make a hundred
million dollars soft a hundred million
dollar problems right so don't chase
money chase problems what are some of
the problems that in the marketplace
that you could solve maybe only you
kiss-off that you could bring to the
marketplace
rule number two change your environment
sometimes I do see your wash
Anabelle what the end the environment
I'm in I'm in a small city and things
like that
move move out of the environment right
your environment is a huge factor right
it plays a huge factor when it comes to
success and fulfillment in life so if
you don't like where you are in where
you're located and there are not a lot
of opportunities move you see those
signs right highway you can get in the
car and move you're gonna play and move
if you want it bad enough do it find a
way whatever it takes because you need
to operate in an environment where it is
beneficial and supportive of the vision
that you have for yourself so I think
location matters a lot and I think
environment if if anything look at
environment meaning who you surround
yourself with if you don't have a lot of
good people that you can surround
yourself with where you're located you
have to get out of there you have to go
to places where where the action is that
right where things are happening maybe
it's a big city it doesn't always have
to be a big city but you see the people
that you meet the people do the people
that you are able to to interact with
opportunities just they open up rule
number three get more productive in
front computer you're working on it
let's say two three four hours straight
non-stop you notice how you lose focus
and your boutique yeah right
productivity side you can see like at
first like yeah first hour but then even
you're doing the work but after a few
hours you're like you can see you feel
you know your proteins going down after
like four or five hours right anyway
yeah so cuz human beings we're not
designed to do that I'll break and all
that we actually design the way that we
work it's more like a like a sprint
right so what intensely could be 40 45
minute 15 minutes
yes break then do another 45 minute
break
right that's how I you gotta look him in
you to schedule your time we're not
designed to work five six hours trick no
brick you know you're not your
creativity right you're not very
productive after few hours because we
have not designed that's why we lose
focus and you kindly kind of see the
self blurry in front of you you know
you're not as sharp
you're not as quarry rule number four
have a purpose why Elon Musk why Jack Ma
why Warren Buffett why Bill Gates why
all of them still work you look at the
Forbes 500 the 500 richest people on the
planet guess what they all still work
most of them still work why they don't
need the money right this is a poor
person's question I'll tell you why
because you don't know what we Taemin is
like when I retired at your twenty seven
I was bored out of my mind see most
people most people who have the employee
mentality because they hate what they do
they don't like what they do so they
have this fantasy they want to get to a
point where I don't have to work anymore
I don't need to go to work right they'll
be sitting on a beach being a beach bum
with something all day right anything
that's yep that's my ultimate dream
because that's how they've been
fantasizing this whole thing when the
wealthiest people on the planet they
have retired they have retired not from
something not doing nothing but they
have retired to their businesses what
they are passionate about what they love
to do they wake up every morning there
is a purpose this is a sense of purpose
there is something that they look
forward to versus most people there's
nothing they look forward to do like
what they do they're not good at what
they do right when you have actually
experienced it you probably have not
experienced it but if you have
experienced it then you know yeah where
time is not what it's all cracked up to
be it's boring and if you look at law
studies a lot of people who retired at
age 65 and they got nothing to do guess
what they are bored and surely after
that they die
because there's no purpose as a human
being we need to grow also if you want
to have more confidence and self-love
check out my 254 series they're free the
link to join are in the description
below after you practice martial art you
develop this natural self confidence not
cockiness when you develop this natural
self confidence that's a problem with
young people you're not good at anything
oh I'm so good no tell me the truth
you're not good at anything remember
this your business is always a
reflection of you rule number five learn
how to multiply money money secret
number five and that is money moves to
those who know how to multiply I want
you to look at the richest people in the
world some of the richest people in the
world they are money managers they are
investors now why do people throw money
at them because they know how to
multiply money they know how to generate
good returns for their investors it's
very simple once you know how to
multiply money you don't have to chase
money money chases you I remember back
then when I was a teenager when I was
asking the bank to give me a credit card
a credit card for $1000 and they
wouldn't give that to me
why because if back then I didn't know
how money works I didn't know how to
multiply money right they wouldn't even
give me a credit card a limit of $1,000
and now the bank's call me and say mr.
Locke do you need loan do you want to
buy a building do you want to expand
your business we're more than happy to
give you a huge line of credit unsecured
why because they know I know how to
multiply money now rule number six
provide great customer service
recently I was in Los Angeles and my
team and I we went out for dinner one
night
and we went to Korean town now Korean
town there's a famous Korean barbeque
place so we we serve a table we showed
up it's a very interesting experience I
want to share with you because there are
a couple key lessons key customer
service lessons from there first of all
we showed up and we were waiting for
almost half
our because the place is packed so I was
getting a little impatient right little
like what's going on right guys
my time is valuable by just waiting in
all of us a dozen of us out waiting for
a table with so before going in I know
that place is good but I was like man I
don't know just like it so my
expectation was like not so good is I
don't know I know the food is good but I
don't know how good the experience is
gonna be right so before we were seated
we weren't in a very good mood right and
so we wanted to sit together but because
they don't have a table of that size we
were forced to sit in two separate
tables to separate and Jenna was like oh
this is no good so starting now I was
already like okay let's let's the the
waiter they're not getting any tips here
I don't care the food is good at not
getting pissed because the customer
service is not that good now however
once we we are we were seated then you
have the waiter coming and explaining
the different types of food that they
have now they serve meat it's Korea
barbecue we have like different kinds of
beef many like so many different kinds
right they barbecue I don't know it's
different parts of the the beef and
different kinds of people very very
delicious
not only you notice but when it comes to
Korean restaurant they give you a lot of
free appetizers so each one of us got
like a lot of these small boats of
appetizers I'm like okay this is this is
pretty good right so we order the food
the the waiter actually came to our
table and we have just like grill in
front of us and they would actually cook
for us they would cut off the meat and
they were cooked it and and then they
were served I said like okay okay now we
remember the beginning my expectation
was here you see when it comes to
customer service a lot of that has to do
with managing expectations we will
eating it's great it's awesome like okay
this is like it's better and the waiter
actually was taking a time to educate us
on different types of meat that we can
order like which one oh you want to try
this one you wanna try that one but he
then he did something very smart and
that's what I want to share with you
near about two-thirds of the way so we
ordered rains and pops and Desmond drink
this beer right if that's made you're
watching this right and then it's good
we have a great time we were chatting
we're eating and I want to thoughts in
the way they were bringing us free
drinks a you know what they brought
along a couple bottles of beer and they
brought couple uh a lot of pop and
drinks just boom put a table on the
house now you don't see this in an
impatient restaurant a lot just so you
know I'm like this is smart first of all
the drinks cost very little money
compared to what we what we eat we feel
like wow this is this is very nice we
get free appetizers now we have free
drinks but here's the thing by the time
we're almost done eating even you give
us more free drinks we can't finish them
anyway so chances are they'll take this
back back to the kitchen right it's a
wheel we're not consuming the the free
stuff but the feeling was very good
right and at the end we actually end up
tipping the the waiters quite a bit over
tipping them so customer service what
could you learn from this story a few
things number one managing expectations
number two is the little thing it's a
little thing that counts when you have
providers like you know the nice small
gestures right the small little things
not the big things that people remember
you people remember what you've done you
go that extra mile right and number
three is educating your customers
because I always believe an informed
customer is a better customer so imagine
we're just eating a food maybe we didn't
order the type of meat that would taste
good but by educating us okay if you
want this kind of texture you want this
kind of taste you want marinated not
marinated you want different parts of
the beef by educating us then we're like
okay this is this is nice right and how
to properly eat the meat right even okay
you mix it with the sauce this is what
you do did you dip in this and this how
eat okay this is it creates a better
experience for us rule number seven
spend your time and money wisely young
people just like myself when I was
younger you
would spend time on playing video games
right and you would spend a lot of time
watching like following sports right
watching this game in that game and
before you know and you're wasting a lot
of time instead of using that time to
improve yourself because when you're 20
years old you don't think about 30 40 50
years right when you're 50 when you when
you're 55 but I'm telling you it feels
like yesterday I was 21 a blink of an
eye
yeah now like 30 a blink of an eye
you're like 40 time passed by so fast
and you will wish that hey you know what
if I didn't waste their time doing all
those super things and I'll say don't
play game I've got a ps4 and xboxone
right I play it from a couple times a
month you just don't want to a dude 3
hours of gaming every day unless you are
streamer that's how you're making your
money but then you know what no problem
with that I think it's like the mobile
games to that yeah yeah 10 minutes here
10 minutes here and especially those
mobile games where you gotta buy more
cool microtransaction you know where
they hope you in with free game before
you know it you spend hundreds of
dollars yeah there was a game that I
bought with just a Chinese game like a
three kingdoms like a strategy game free
download before you know it I was
blowing hundreds and hundreds of dollars
it's stupid
right and that money is something that
you could use two words educating
yourself largest form education by self
education reading books taking online
courses or even going to events or
learning from someone who is successful
rule number eight be prepared to go
through rejections let's say your
closing ratio is 25% it means that you
closed one out of four you're pretty
darn good right a 25% closing ratio and
let's say you want to close a hundred
years a hundred cells what does that
mean it means that you get that hundred
cells to get a hundred yeses you need to
get 300
knows you will not get to that 100 yeses
without the 300 nose I remember at the
beginning of my career I was selling and
closing my own services on the phone and
every single time when I get a no I
would be so disappointed with myself I
would be very frustrated right I would
get very upset I would get angry why
couldn't I close that cell then I would
beat myself up I would have a lot of
self-doubt but you see because I didn't
understand what I'm sharing with you
right now you cannot get to those of
yeses weed out the nose it is part of
the game that's why we do what we do to
get through those yeses you must go
through a lot of knows rule number nine
be prepared to make sacrifices I believe
everyone could be an entrepreneur but
not everyone shoot in entrepreneur just
like anyone can play possible anyone
could grab a ball and choose some boots
but not everyone would begin to you envy
you because you see most people when
they see someone who is successful who
easy successful what you preneur anyone
can start but you can start business
sofa partnership incorporate a few
hundred bucks a few couple grand but you
are in business anyone can change the
Instagram and say I don't know I'm the
founder and CEO of whatever my company
is low beer of entry but the problem is
starting out as an entrepreneur there's
a video last as I see most people when
they see entrepreneurship do you think a
man is like this on flying private jet
the destination of joy - life is good
that's not what entrepreneurship yes in
fact let me ask a question comment below
for my fans who follow my work who are
business owners that you have started
your only business especially retail
business comment below share your story
what is it in life to be an entrepreneur
if I was to ask you the question why you
want to start your business you might
say I want more freedom I want more free
time right I want to want to make more
money here's what happens after you
start your business before you start
your own business you're working five
days a week eight hours a day a typical
job it's fine
after you become entrepreneur now you're
not working five days
you're not working six days a week
they're working seven days a week
you're not working it out today they're
not working ten hours a day you're
working for 14 hours a day making less
money with a lot more stress and
probably
yes tell me this is not true right and
you think it's gonna take you oh I'm
gonna be successful in one year think
you will take you one year turns out
even after you're successful and talk to
you five and 15 20 years this is the
glamorous I no one talks about the dark
side right you've heard of statistics 95
percent of small businesses feel in the
first five years right some people say
ninety six percent the 5% is survives it
doesn't mean they're like thriving
they're just surviving and big majority
of that five percent most of them don't
make it so you have to understand what
you're getting yourself into
and you'll number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun hi mr. prospect
hi mr. prospect how are you today sir
hey mr. prospect how are you today sir
okay no sweaty palms oh my god Mustangs
yes yes yes I hear my champion
I am a champion now I have a special
bonus clip from Dan on how to figure out
your magic number that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
the three-point landing questions let's
go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go
questionable how can you have more fun
in your business number two how can you
provide better customer service this
week number three what's one simple
change you can make to your environment
today you have to know your magic number
you have to know your magic number I'm
not talking about doing a magic trick
I'm talking about magic number okay what
is a magic number the reason you're not
making the kind of money that you want
to make is because you have not made it
a must a must to continually increase
the worth of your time hustling working
on things and a lot of activities very
busy but you have not made it a must it
is not an intention it is not a goal to
continue to increase the worth of your
time think about the people that you
just mentioned the people that hustling
hard all their lives
you know working hard but they never
slow down and step back and say what can
I do to increase the value of my time
what can I do to to improve my my
earning potential right they never ask
that it just you know what if I'm making
minimum wage with one job let me just
get a second job
mmm-hmm that's hustling Nerissa's hey
you know what the the hourly rate that
I'm making this is not enough what can I
do to be worth more it's a very
different way of thing hi this is Dan
Locke if you're a fan of Evans work if
you want to know exactly how the model
my success I
want to invite you to join me for a
special online training all you have to
do is click on a link below you can join
me for absolutely no charge so click a
link below and I will see you in class
and if you want more Dan lock check at
the top 50 rules for success video I
made on him the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there many
years ago I had this conversation with
my mentor and he asked me the question
Dan what do you think is the number one
quality of an entrepreneur